the reason i'm wearing this shirt today
is uh it's national wear red day for
women's heart health heart disease is a
huge risk
for women so please get your numbers
checked your cholesterol your blood
pressure your blood sugar and now that
mine is through the roof talking about
it
let's get some good news pumping through
those yes we can all right kick us off
today
all right
so much changed happened during the
first season of just like that and the
epic finale was last night we're so and
just like that it's over but wait
there's more people reports hbo max just
released a behind-the-scenes documentary
all about the making of season one so if
you want to see like carrie bradshaw
her real name sarah jessica parker she's
carrie bradley in my mind she's both but
you get to see sjp
flip in to carrie bradshaw and we have
an exclusive look take
[Music]
tomorrow we have the very first scenes
in the show
[Applause]
even 23 years in i'm excited terrified
and excited you know
i'm so into this i can't even talk about
it so into this
i i think um i really think that it took
us a minute to try all these new
fabulous clothes on and i i really
appreciate it i love it i hope it comes
back for season two i've been on the
ride yes and i think they did a
tremendous job and it's very popular and
everybody's talking about it i think
that is not easy to do no it's not and
i feel like
i feel like after watching this first
season we had death we had new friends
we have divorces i need to speak to a
therapist after watching the first the
first thing but i'm here for a second
one because i need to see carrie happy
again yeah please bring on season two
and just like that and yet that is life
birth death loss grieving celebrating
changes you know radical themes
i'm very glad it wasn't just pop and
bottles and fabulous outfits actually
they gave us real life right
yeah i'm here for it um well speaking of
changes and outfits it took 94 years but
minnie mouse is finally getting some
pants wow that's right cnn report she's
creating a red dress for our custom blue
polka dot pantsuit designed by the one
the only stella
look
mccartney
this month in honor of women's history
month and the 30th anniversary of
disneyland paris now if we could only
figure out why goofy gets to wear
clothes but pluto is naked as a jay bird
someone get him something to wear but a
personal note from me to my friend
stella mccartney she is the one and only
she has been at the forefront of
being
eco-minded
uh walking the walk talking the talk and
i'm so excited to see
our world finally embracing what she's
been saying for the last 30 years and i
can't think of a better woman
for international women's day and minnie
mouse to be given a makeover by ms
stella mccartney congratulations to
everyone involved
all right
your story all right next up an adorable
story from idaho the washington post
reports an eight-year-old writer named
dylan hellberg wrote his own book and
then slipped it into the shelf at his
local public library
boy dylan admits it was kind of naughty
to do so the library staff they loved
the book so much that they slapped a
barcode on it and loaned it out and now
his book the adventures of dylan
helberg's christmas has a waiting list
of 55 names he's a hit
about that
and now dylan is working on another book
uh about a closet that eats jackets
which sounds like a nightmare
to me let me tell my closet try it i'll
come in there and hunt you down but what
about this talk about and i think the
number one key to to success in life is
initiative right people don't have
strong contact yes
his illustrations really speak to me his
initiative speaks to me and his concepts
speak to me yeah i'm almost like afraid
i'm having like a weird moment where i'm
like i've got to get to this kid you do
you and i believe it
i need to deal with that
i love having yes
and i love that dylan wanted to see his
book on the shelf and so he put his book
on the shelf and you know i'll take a
lesson the mom brought him back to the
library so that they could sort of she
was there to say you know you shouldn't
do that and the library was like well we
actually have the book and people want
to check it out can we put a barcode on
it absolutely
well something else i know you love drew
you're obsessed with that show
yellowstone right so this story is for
you
thrillist reports there's a new hot
property on the market in colorado it's
just 4.7 million dollars but you can buy
an entire old western town a whole town
it's just a few hours from denver and it
looks like a town on the west on the
outside but on the inside it is fully
modern you've got yourself a saloon
beautiful right yes saloon a general
store
a dance hall all built with modern
plumbing it's got 22 beds and 24
bathrooms so that's that i mean i can
get behind that ratio and but i when i
heard about this i was like this is so
up drew's alley would you move in i have
literally stalked this i've looked at
all the pictures
[Music]
you